Viral Mark Zuckerberg for a day.
First,
I would buy more hoodies in different
colors.
The second I would discuss with my
senior team,
the practice of edgerank as it impacts
people's personal profiles,
so visa vi brands were brands are
getting less organic views so they have
to pay up to promote.
Hallelujah.
Take them for all you can.
You deserve that,
but I think that it's kind of dangerous
where trixie and biff,
if they have a baby or if they graduate
from college and they put up their
graduation picture,
I think they think that if they have a
thousand followers,
all thousand people can see it and from
what I've heard,
and I don't know if it's true,
but if it's true,
not 1000 people will see it.
Maybe 100 people will see it.
And I think that if trixie and bf start
losing confidence that facebook is the
way to post their life story to
everybody who has voluntarily follow
them,
that you could be throwing out the baby
with the bathwater.
And if enough people think this way and
they stop using facebook,
then you won't be able to charge the
brands for promoting their posts.
So again,
I'm on the outside looking in.
I know how these algorithms work,
if there are any algorithms like that.
But I think that's really playing with
fire.